[Music]  please be a 5-star ride  [Music]  five cheeseburgers five cheeseburgers no  onions no pickles no onions no pickles  just a sprinkle of cocaine  they don't have cocaine zty I'm not  gonna  basic screwed on my eyes good this is  uber and you know how easy it is to get  a driver to take you anywhere you want  to go it's happening tonight  uber yeah okay  drive I'm still how do you do  Koreatown no hold on get a banger UE  here real quick  no don't got it  [Music]  take this gun why do you have so many  guns different sort of militia Oh  another good man you are really  overcompensating for you  [Applause]  [Music]  how do you know my dad he kidnapped me  we didn't kill anyone  [Applause]  hello operator we need help someone's  trying to murder us  [Music]